in the first century there lived a man
who became famous as a kind of wandering
Sage he would live a life of celibacy
walk around preaching and Performing
various Miracles such as driving out
demons and even Reviving the dead he was
seen by some as a kind of divine man
maybe even the son of God and at the end
of his life he was taken up to heaven
never to be seen again
and no I am not talking about Jesus of
Nazareth but rather about apollonius of
Tiana one of the most fascinating
figures from late Antiquity I totally
stole that intro from The Scholar Bart
ehrmann but in any case apollonius of
Tiana was a Pythagorean philosopher who
became known for performing Miracles and
who lived a life that at least according
to the famous stories about his life
seemed to mirror in quite a lot of
significant ways the famous stories
about the life of Jesus Christ in the
Christian narratives but who was
apollonius what do we know about his
life and what can we say about his
connection to the most central figure in
Christianity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the first century was certainly a very
eventful period it included events that
would come to shape the history of the
world the destruction of Jerusalem the
fire of Rome and of course the life and
Ministry of Jesus of Nazareth whose
following would eventually turn into the
largest religion in the world we've
discussed the life of Jesus in previous
episodes and explored the question
whether or not he existed as a
historical person
the scholarly consensus is that Jesus
was a real guy who lived in Judea in the
first half of the first century there
are many reasons for these conclusions
but one of the most telling ones in my
opinion is that Jesus wasn't really all
that unique at least from a certain
perspective there were many people like
Jesus at that time and in that region
people who claimed to be the Messiah
people who opposed the Roman authorities
who had became famous for walking around
performing miracles
so why would Jesus in particular be made
up if all these other similar people
were real not one such figure in which
we find many similarities is indeed that
of apollonius of Tiana a really colorful
character from roughly around Cappadocia
and Anatolia and who would wander around
the Hellenic and Mediterranean world as
a kind of holy man
comparisons where Jesus are made all the
time on the life of apollonius is often
used as an argument against the
legitimacy of Christ but things aren't
that simple and the subject is often
sensationalized and misrepresented so
what is actually going on with
apollonius who was he
well the first thing that we must be
aware of is the fact that basically all
information we have about this guy and
his life comes from later sources in
particular the vast majority of our
information comes from a text called the
life of apollonius of Tiana written in
the third Century by a guy called
philistratus in other words almost two
centuries after he died furthermore
since felastrados was a so-called
sophist the text is written in a style
that is meant to be first and foremost
entertaining it contains many shops and
stylistic features common from text from
this era and many aspects of the text
weren't even meant to be historically
accurate necessarily but more so
entertaining legendary stories in other
words much if not all about
philistrada's rights needs to be taken
with a huge grain of salt now we do have
other sources too we have for example
letters that are attributed to
apollonius himself many of which are
uncertain in terms of their authenticity
but Scholars argue that some of them may
actually date back to the guy himself
and these other sources can also tell us
more about him or at least the public
perception about who he was needless to
say it's very difficult to say anything
with certainty about the actual
historical figure of apollonius and it's
much easier to talk about the legendary
apollonius Right the apollonius as he is
re told or described in the famous
accounts like in philistratus's life of
apollonius of Tiana but it might be
possible to extract some of the
information from these more
hegeographical accounts to get an idea
of who this guy could actually have been
so based on these sources that we do
have access to what can we say about the
life of apollonius
well he's primarily remembered as a kind
of Wonder working Sage the stories tend
to categorize him as a Pythagorean
philosopher or to be more accurate a
so-called neo-pythagorean philosopher
but this doesn't mean that he was a
philosopher in the sense of having a
bunch of knowledge about things or
speculating about the nature of reality
as we saw in the episode about
Pythagoras being a quote-unquote
Pythagorean could mean a bunch of
different things apollonius lived in the
1st Century A.D and at this point
neopythagoreanism and a philosophical
sense had become strongly associated
with ideas surrounding numbers that the
fundamentals of reality was made up of
numbers or mathematics and primarily
that the most fundamental principle of
reality was that of a monad or the one
which would become so Central in late
platonism
but as we discussed pythagoreanism was
also strongly associated with a certain
quote-unquote Pythagorean way of life
there was a certain way in which you
could be your behave like a Pythagorean
and while number speculation may have
played a role in the thought of
apollonius it is not so much ideas that
he is associated with but exactly this
way of Behaving and being which was
characterized as Pythagorean what does
this mean well pythagoreans were kind of
expected to be something similar to what
we would call hippies today they would
have long beards long hair and wear
patched clothing a Pythagorean would
usually follow a vegetarian diet have a
certain mysterious way of speaking or
not speaking and would often wander
around a lot from place to place because
Pythagoras himself was associated with
miraculous and almost Divine Powers so
the later pythagoreans were often
expected to be able to perform Miracles
or superhuman Feats on account of the
incredible power of the secret
Pythagorean wisdoms that they held and
apollonius basically fits into all of
these characteristics he was a age
probably a vegetarian with a beard and
long hair who walked around the Hellenic
world and Beyond doing miraculous things
and the stories about his life are
amazingly rich and fascinating it is
said that even before he was born his
mother was visited by the god Proteus to
announce the birth of this amazing Sage
the birth itself is similarly colorful
as his mother is said to have been
surrounded by Swans as she was giving
birth now this has led many to associate
this with the birth of the god Apollo
which is also accompanied by Swans and
Swan Song and this gives fuel to the
idea that apollonius might have been
seen by many as a kind of God on Earth
or Divine being especially connected to
the god Apollo as is of course suggested
in his name apollonius although
philistratus doesn't say anything about
his Divine or non-divine nature in the
actual text his birth is also
accompanied by other Heavenly signs such
as Thunder and other things and already
we're starting to see similarities with
other Divine figures including of course
the story of Christ but we're getting
ahead of ourselves nonetheless Apollonia
is was probably from Tiana in Asia Minor
as his name suggests and grew up to be a
kind of philosopher as he studied under
some pythagoreans but his fate isn't
sealed until he makes a fateful journey
to India
this journey to India makes up a
significant part of the life of
apollonius and tells of how he traveled
there to meet and study with the
brahmanas who were according to him the
true Originators of Pythagorean Doctrine
in other words instead of studying with
pythagoreans back home he went straight
to the source not counting Pythagoras
himself of course
and that is supposedly here that he
learns all his amazing wisdom and Powers
because when he returns to the West he
immediately becomes known as a sage and
people start to gather around him for
the rest of his life apollonius would
wander around the Mediterranean world he
would go to Greek cities in Anatolia he
went to Egypt and many other places
and in all these places he is said to
have performed Miracles he would cast
out demons he healed the sick he could
just like Pythagoras himself
miraculously appear in different places
at the same time and many other
Fantastical stories there are even
stories of how he basically raises
people from the dead in one very
fascinating account he is said to have
visited the Oracle of trifonius now this
Oracle of trifonius was Infamous for
being very very difficult it was a very
heavy experience the person who went
there would go down and descend into a
dark cave and come out almost
traumatized by the experience which may
or may not have included some
psychoactive compounds it probably did
there are stories about people who would
forget how to laugh for a long period
after going down into this cave so it's
a serious experience but apollonius
however of course seems completely
unfazed by the whole thing like the
total badass that he is so Apollonia
certainly comes off as an incredibly
charismatic and colorful character he
would have been seen as a pretty strange
figure even for his time many of these
things that he was associated with made
him a very unique figure just the fact
that he lived a life of celibacy was
seen by most people as a complete
mystery especially in pre-christian
times right this was just a just this
weird thing for someone to do we could
sit here all day and just recount
stories about apollonius as life because
they are all so fascinating in one
account he stops one of his students
from marrying a vampire he could see
into the future the stories are just
endless as for his philosophical beliefs
so to say we can't really say that much
again this wasn't what he was associated
with or famous for
but being a Pythagorean in the lifestyle
we might also assume or guess that he
would also have held certain ideas
associated with Pythagoras too like the
importance of numbers and geometry
perhaps reincarnation and the
immortality of the Soul some accounts
suggest that he would have held an idea
of God the Supreme as being Transcendent
above the world and therefore not in
need of anything from us which we can
see from his apparent rejection of
animal sacrifice which was a practice
that was as you probably know incredibly
common in Antiquity most ancient
religions had some form of animal
sacrifice and Apollonia seems to have
rejected this practice and this can be
seen for example from one of the texts
that is actually attributed to
apollonius himself called on sacrifice
quotes to him we must not Kindle Fire or
make promise unto him of any sensible
object whatsoever
for he needs nothing even from beings
higher than ourselves we should make use
in relation to him solely the higher
speech I mean that which issues not by
the lips and from the noblest faculty we
possess and that faculty is intelligence
which needs no organ
on these principles then we ought not on
any account to sacrifice to the mighty
and supreme god
here we see him having ideas similar to
philosophies associated with platonism
and pythagoreanism which are so closely
connected of course which imagines the
Divine as a mind or noose and that our
way of communicating with God is through
this news and of us somehow ascending to
this noetic world of the intellect and
through there communicating with God and
not through this material world through
sacrifices and such things certainly he
lived an endlessly fascinating life and
his death is equally interesting indeed
the death of apollonius is a kind of
mystery in itself
even philistratus who writes the life of
apollonius admits that he doesn't really
know what happened to him
some stories say that he somehow got
into trouble with the Roman authorities
and was put on trial but that he
suddenly disappeared from the courtroom
never to be seen again
a common idea among his followers and
admirers was that he never actually died
but that his soul was taken up into the
heavens that he just up and disappeared
one day traveling to the higher planes
of existence
apollonius of Tiana is a figure that
baffles us even still today all the
stories about his life as written in in
the life of apollonius by philistratus
are of course Very Fantastical
um and as we've seen they also mirror in
many ways the life and stories about
Jesus Christ in the Christian accounts
but how much of this life story of
apollonius is actually chew remember
philistratus wrote almost two centuries
after apollonius lived and he was also a
sophist that was primarily interested or
concerned with entertaining his audience
and for these reasons we should
be careful and we should be doubtful of
a lot of the information that he gives
us in his book did apollonius actually
travel to India for example
there is of course a possibility but
it's also a very convenient way to
connect him to his master Pythagoras who
is also said to have made the same
Journey
not to mention the common ancient Trope
of traveling to the east to find wisdom
and what about all these Miracles and
travels in the West in short we can't
really know much at all about
apollonia's as a historical person even
here there are similarities between him
and Jesus because these scholarly
consensus on them is pretty similar just
like with Jesus it is generally agreed
that apollonius was probably a real
person in some regard but that most of
the stories about him are later
interpolations it also might be safe to
assume that he was a Pythagorean who
became famous for wandering around the
Hellenic World performing Miracles but
much more if even that can't really be
said
again he fits into a kind of common
tendency of wandering miracle workers of
this time period even in the Jewish
World we have figures like honey the
circle jar and perhaps even Shimon by
Yokai the famed main character and
mythical author of The Zohar as examples
of similar figures in the region at the
time and at this point I guess we should
discuss the elephant in the room which
is the huge number of similarities
between the life of apollonius and that
of Jesus as it is told in the gospels
from the miraculous birth accompanied by
Divine Science to performing similar
Miracles
even to his death or non-death there are
too many similarities to be a
coincidence here right again
philistratus's life of apollonius of
Tiana which is the source where we get
the vast majority of our stories about
him was written in the 3rd century
not only is this long after the figuring
question lived but also after the gospel
accounts of Jesus had been written and
basically been considered Canon
with this in mind many scholars today
argue that one of the main purposes of
philistratus is writing this work on
apollonius was as a kind of response to
the Christians who by that point had
become quite a powerful community in a
way apollonius is constructed as the
Pagan version of Christ
he's portrayed as doing all the things
Jesus did and even more in fact
this is a way for philistratus to show
that basically look we have holy men
like you too your Jesus isn't so special
after all so I think the answer lies
somewhere in there many of these
similarities may have been due to the
fact that figures like them were
relatively common in the first century
and the very particular parallels
between them may have been a direct
response against the Christians and the
biblical accounts by philistratus but we
can be thankful for such inter-religious
conversation even if it isn't so
friendly in this case because it gives
us such fascinating stories as that of
the life of apollonius of Tiana truly
one of the most interesting figures of
late Antiquity even without the
connections to other more famous people
again it's hard to say how much of the
stories about MR2 but even if we accept
just the bare minimum as authentic we
are still left with an incredibly
intriguing and inspiring Sage slash
Divine man slash philosopher Pythagorean
of the kind that makes studying ancient
history and philosophy so much fun
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank all my patrons over on patreon
truly none of this would be possible
without you and I am so eternally
grateful for all your support thanks to
your help I am able to do this as a
major part of my life studying these
things and conveying all this
information to the larger audience
including you guys all for free
basically and and that is truly a
blessing so thank you thank you so so so
much I would like to give a very special
shout out to all my patrons of the saint
category and there are a few ones some
I've already given a shout out to before
and some new faces as well so a special
thank you to wasif Khan while Muhammad
Thomas Blaze Oleg K
ccb6b325 to
ee33c84 suhail gokal Faris badawi Mary
Carmen ordones while Osiris Marcel White
El gamma Khaled Rosa Brian King Emilio
Dominguez fawaz Al mubaraki Jordan
Friedman sankalp and Yara Amar
again thank you thank you so much not
just the ones I just mentioned but all
of you who support me on patreon and of
course all of you out there who are
watching commenting and and just
engaging with these videos in general it
really means so much to me and I'm so
happy to be able to provide free
educational content it really is a
blessing so thank you so much and I will
see you next time
[Music]
thank you